hey everyone welcome to another
installment of Harry Potter Theory today
we're going to be discussing a bit of
Harry Potter news specifically news
pertaining to the possibility of a new
Harry Potter TV show a few days ago
reports of this alleged show began
flooding my news feeds across nearly
every social media platform and it's
been sent to me countless times so I
thought I'd add my two cents the
headline which originated on
bloomberg.com reads Warner Bros nears
deal for Harry Potter online TV series
the article then goes on to detail how
and why this new Harry Potter series may
happen Warner Bros Discovery Inc is
close to a deal for a new online TV
series based on Harry Potter the
best-selling young adult books according
to two people with knowledge of the
matter each season of the series will be
based on one of JK Rowling's seven books
said the people who asked not to be
identified since the deal hasn't been
announced suggesting years of fresh fare
from the popular Stories the company is
hoping this series can be one
cornerstone of a new streaming strategy
that will be announced next week by
HBO's parent Warner Bros that company's
chief executive officer David zaslav and
HBO Chief Casey bloys have worked to
convince Rowling to produce a new series
but the deal hasn't been completed to
some who may not follow Harry Potter
news as closely as I do this certainly
sounds exciting however I for one am not
going to fall victim to another faux
Harry Potter reboot announcement for
years I've seen articles like this one
and it's getting a lot more difficult to
take them seriously mainly because
nothing ever seems to actually happen
there's always a lot of awaiting
confirmation cited in these articles
which is often another way of saying we
hope this happens but we have very
little proof in the past six months
alone I've seen a huge influx in these
announcements likely due to the fact
that Hogwarts Legacy has made Harry
Potter topical again it was only a few
months ago that a new cursed Child movie
appeared to be the next big thing on the
horizon something I was extremely
skeptical of but while the success of
Hogwarts Legacy may have paved the way
for an internet-wide trend of false
promises its success may have also paved
a more legitimate path forward this is
the first time in years that Harry
Potter has been trending on such a large
scale something we owe to the game and
so it would make sense the Warner Bros
would be looking to capitalize on this
popularity prior to the release of the
game The Wizarding World was starting to
feel less and less inspired with each
subsequent Harry Potter prequel failing
harder than the last at least from a box
office perspective I like the Fantastic
Beasts films but they certainly weren't
Harry Potter and their box office
failures probably didn't motivate water
Bros very much to start creating even
more Harry Potter content the bad news
this article could just be another false
promise the good news Harry Potter is
back in a big way I don't think that's
arguable and I don't see how or why
Warner Bros could possibly fail to
capitalize on the revitalization of one
of their biggest pieces of Ip and that's
it for this video what do you think if
you enjoy the content please like the
video and subscribe to the channel until
next time remember it does not do to
dwell on dreams and forget to live
foreign